- carrot you didn't think I was afraid
the first time I went out in the field
I believe you keep citing its a pseudo
roulette we have got to stop meeting
like this if you go looking for trouble
you always fine
you're bleeding
hey youtubers is Charlie so this is
Kevin Smith Supergirl episode it's based
on his movie Superman lives it's the
insane Ben Affleck Superman movie that
turned into the even crazier Nicolas
Cage Tim Burton Superman movie so I'll
explain all that it is fantastically
weird there is a new round of the flash
ring giveaway that's going on - all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
leave a comment on this video be sure to
click that Bell to enable alerts so you
don't miss anything so what's going on
here this is Supergirl episode 9 its
Kevin Smith's episode the title
Supergirl lives is a reference to the
unproduced movie that he wrote the
screenplay for it called Superman lives
which I'll explain in a second because
it is the craziest Superman story that
you've ever heard of it is ridiculous
which makes me think that they're going
to be borrowing some concepts from that
they're not going to be doing Superman
lives but they're going to be doing some
stuff from that Kevin Smith said it's
the biggest episode of TV that he's ever
directed in terms of comic book deep
cuts characters that he's loved so like
for instance the Eradicator was a big
part of his Superman live script so I'm
wondering if they're gonna introduce the
Eradicator on Supergirl
it also looks like she passes through a
gateway to a planet with a red Sun
that's also part of the story of
Superman lives
the evil duo of lex luthor and brainiac
turned our yellow sun red to take away
Superman's powers so he's powerless for
a lot of the film you can start to see
why they didn't produce this Superman
lives movie but I'll explain the plot of
that in greater detail in a second but
it looks like what's happening here is
just Supergirl is losing her powers
because of the red Sun but you also have
this alien ship these aliens were teased
at the end of the Supergirl crossover
episode during the big four night
crossover
my Lords we've reached the well of stars
and there is no sign of the Kryptonian
pod find it the ion trail has dissipated
I would not know where to look I didn't
I do not care how much space we must
cross how many lives we lose or how many
Suns we burn they sound like they might
be the dominators from this universe but
they were all wearing helmets so you
couldn't really tell they were looking
for a special nebula like a special area
of space that brought Mon L to earth so
that place might be tied to this gateway
here but the dominators are coming back
whether or not these aliens are them the
dominators that we saw during the four
night crossover will be coming back to
Supergirl in the back half of the season
but because it's Supergirl she's in a
different universe they might be the
dominators from her universe not from
the universe in earth one so not
technically the same dominators even
though it's the same race of beings so
just from a different universe roulette
is back it seems like she has some
mysterious connection to these aliens
and the ship so we'll learn about that
during the back cap of the season it
seems like Roulettes gonna be a larger
character over the back half which is
cool Deccan lachman's great actress she
was really good on the 100 show she was
really good on dollhouse so Superman
lives let's talk about this monstrosity
this was the Ben Affleck Superman movie
that turned into the Tim Burton Nicolas
Cage Superman movie there was several
different versions of it Saul tried to
explain everything Kevin Smith was
heavily involved at the script stage he
kind of remembers it fondly now in
retrospect but this is like many many
years later it was around 1996 1997 when
they were in production so this is a
long time ago so you have to imagine the
younger version of Kevin Smith just
signed when he was asked to make all
these compromises in the script so the
important figures here Kevin Smith was
the person that was working on the
screenplay
he pitched it to John Peters who was the
producer the director was going to be
Tim Burton so I guess you could think of
it as Tim Burton's version of Superman
but really most of the stuff we know
about this isn't talking to Kevin Smith
because he wrote the screenplay so
listen to some of these beats that the
producers wanted Kevin Smith to write
into the screenplay Smith
that he was a hired gun and as such he
had to do whatever they asked for so
even if they asked for ridiculous stuff
which they definitely did which I'll
explain in a second he just had to write
it into the screenplay
no matter how crazy he thought it was so
this kind of changed over time but at
the start what they asked for was
Superman wearing an all-black suit so
people like okay that doesn't sound so
bad Superman in the black suit just like
the comics they also did not want him to
fly now can you imagine a Superman they
can't fly already you're getting like a
little less excited you're like okay um
you know maybe he'll be like Golden Age
Superman leaping tall buildings in a
single bound but then Kevin Smith came
back and was like no no no he'll fly and
he'll just create sonic booms every time
he does which they'd actually been using
in the more recent movie so that's
actually a pretty cool idea so we have
Superman flying again but then the
producers came back and said okay for
the big climactic fight we want Superman
to fight a giant spider
so naturally Kevin Smith is like that's
the dumbest idea ever and then later you
know after the film fell apart sidenote
Jon Peters also produced that wild wild
west video guess what the big villain
turned into at the end of that movie a
giant spider
so this producer that kevin smith was
forced to work with that was making all
these crazy demands which is obsessed
with giant spiders for some reason but
the list goes on so Kevin Smith you know
being a relatively young person in
Hollywood was just forced to do what the
producers wanted so he started writing
the script but then the producers came
back and said there's not enough action
in the film we want more fight scenes so
because Brainiac was going to be one of
the villains of the film they said we
want Brainiac to fight a polar bear up
at the fortress of solitude so you know
Kevin Smith is just kind of shaking his
head quietly this whole time like no
this is terrible terrible idea and then
because around that time Star Wars was
getting its twentieth anniversary
re-release in theaters if you remember
the special editions that's basically
what it was they rerelease the Star Wars
movies and theaters
so Lucasfilm had all this merchandising
going on
so toy sales were making producers a lot
of money so the producers of Superman
lives were saying okay we want more
things in the movie that we can turn
into toys so that we can make more money
so they asked Kevin Smith to write a dog
a space dog
into the movie that Brainiac would give
to lex luthor just for merchandising
reasons so that we can make a toy from
it not because Brainiac giving lex
luthor a space dog made sense for the
story so then they asked kevin smith to
also write in an assistant for Brainiac
they're like we want him to have a robot
assistant named el ron you guess with
thats code for l ron Hubbard voiced by
Hooper X from chasing Amy and it was
going to be like this gay robot
assistant that's what the producers
called it they said that we want
Brainiac to have a gay robot assistant
just like c-3po this was happening
around the Star Wars special edition
releases so there was a lot of Star Wars
being inserted into movies all over the
place but I do laugh at the idea like
it's so funny just the idea of Hooper X
voicing a robot assistant to Brainiac in
a Superman movie that would be the most
hilarious disaster ever so then Kevin
Smith went away wrote a bunch of the
movie came back in the big part of the
story you know the Superman lives part
of it came from the idea that Brainiac
sent doomsday to kill Superman he
blocked out the Sun so Superman was
powerless and then just like in the
comics you know the return of Superman
Superman is resurrected by the
Eradicator and is able to eventually
defeat Brainiac and Lex Luthor so around
that time Kevin Smith's choice for a
Clark Kent Superman was Ben Affleck so
there was a period of time in the late
90s when Ben Affleck would have been
Superman which is you know pretty
hilarious because he's Batman now I
think it worked out for the better
because when Tim Burton got involved
with the movie that's when it became the
Nicolas Cage monstrosity they changed a
bunch of cannon like it almost became
unrecognizable as a Superman comic book
story so they rewrote Kevin Smith's
version of the story and that's when it
turned into like something that was
really crazy
so like Kevin Smith wrote a version of
the movie that was pretty good
but had a lot of ridiculous things that
the producers asked him to put in but it
was still pretty recognizable as like a
death in return of Superman from the
comics story then when Tim Burton got
involved it got really crazy so like for
instance Superman absorbs solar
radiation from the Yellow Sun that's
what
gives him his power it heals them during
the return of Superman it also brings
him back to life so to speak I mean he
didn't really die he was just very close
to death so in the new crazy Tim Burton
version of the movie he's brought back
to life by the power of K a natural
force representing the spirit of Krypton
the new rider who was rewriting Kevin
Smith's version also combined Lex Luthor
and Brainiac into a single entity called
Lexy ACK so it just sounds like the most
ridiculous thing ever what started out
as a really good idea in Kevin Smith
said as Superman lives was kind of
perverted by Hollywood and then later
totally took it up the butt as people
who didn't care about the comics just
completely tried to change it it turned
into like this 11 year process it had
nothing to do with George Romero's
Justice League that's a completely
separate project this was just a
Superman movie so thank God that it fell
apart you know Kevin Smith was just like
okay you know it was a fun project to
work on but at the time I'm sure it was
just a living nightmare for him but now
you know he's been directing episodes of
the flash
so when Supergirl came to Vancouver he
was like yeah would be awesome to do an
episode of Supergirl so the producer of
Supergirl is the same producer of the
flash and he revealed that Kevin Smith's
episode would be titled Supergirl lives
and Kevin Smith's just started crying he
was like oh thank you so much this is so
wonderful so like I said we don't know
exactly what the plot of his Supergirl
Lives episode is but it sounds like
they're borrowing some beats and some
concepts from his Superman lives
screenplay maybe you like the Eradicator
like he said deep cuts from the comics
so I feel like that's a great tip for
Eradicator and blocking out the Sun
although it looks like red Sun here she
would still lose her powers but that
also means that Brainiac might make an
appearance so if you have a broad idea
of what Superman lives was what do you
think they're gonna do for this
Supergirl lives episode and just re
watching this trailer footage I wish
they cut all their trailers like this
the weird jump cutting the creepy
atmospheric music I'm afraid I feel like
this is a much better version of a
Supergirl trailer than you would
normally see like I really love it when
Supergirl does John Carpenter types
stuff so I'm probably not going to do a
video for this episode but I will do
Supergirl videos
in the future if they do like big comic
book concepts but speaking of Superman I
did say I was gonna do a Superman vs.
doomsday video just because I've
literally done like two superman videos
in a row I'm gonna wait a day and do it
on Wednesday tomorrow will be some new
Marvel just because I've been doing a
whole bunch of DC lately so let me know
if there's any special Superman bonus
videos you guys want me to do during the
break so they also just post it a new
arrow trailer I'll do a video for that
it confirms which version of Laurel is
going to be coming on the show so it's a
pretty big deal so I'll post that in the
morning I'll also say congratulations to
the new flash ring giveaway winner
sacred Shinx just private message me on
the back end of my channel so I can get
your contact details there is a new
round that started in this video I'll
just remind everyone when I post that
arrow video while you guys wait for that
to post you can click here for my Black
Adam vs Superman DC movie video and you
can click here for the trailer for the
flash thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight